Monumental,
farblos,
menschenfeindlich –
die Architektur des Brutalismus.
Es sind Bauwerke, die polarisieren.
Bausünden für die einen.
Doch eine wachsende Zahl
Architekturbegeisterter auf der ganzen Welt
entdeckt den Brutalismus neu.
Ich finde den Brutalismus so faszinierend,
weil es so gegensätzlich und kontrovers ist.
Einerseits werden die Bauwerke
als hässlich verschrien
und sind wirklich vielerorts
sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber wenn man dann ’n bisschen hinter die
Kulissen guckt und anfängt zu verstehen,
warum die Bauwerke so aussehen,
wie sie aussehen,
dann eröffnet sich da so ein ganzer
architektonischer Kosmos.
An ein riesiges Kreuzfahrtschiff erinnert
das Corbusierhaus im Westen Berlins.
Für den Architekturhistoriker
und Fotografen Felix Torkar
ist es eines der wichtigsten brutalistischen
Gebäude der deutschen Hauptstadt,
entworfen 1957
vom französisch-schweizerischen
Architekten Le Corbusier.
530 Wohnungen auf 17 Etagen
– eine sogenannte „Wohnmaschine“.
Le Corbusier ist eigentlich schon der
Namenspate für den Brutalismus,
denn er hat den Begriff „béton brut“, also
rohen, unbehandelten Beton erfunden.
Und er hat ihn bei dieser Baureihe erfunden,
und wenn man sich das Gebäude anschaut,
ist das so ein Riesen-Maschinenungetüm,
das aber gleichzeitig sehr roh geblieben ist.
Im Inneren konnte Le Corbusier
seine Pläne nicht verwirklichen.
Nur eine Wohnung wurde nachträglich
originalgetreu umgestaltet,
basierend auf der von ihm
entwickelten Farbenlehre.
Für Le Corbusier waren Farben genauso
wichtig wie Grundriss und Schnitt.
Der Schwede Henrik Svedlund
war sofort fasziniert
und kaufte die Wohnung
samt der meisten Möbel.
Wir werden die Farben
in dieser Wohnung niemals ändern.
Niemals!
Es ist wie ein Kartenhaus.
Es kann ganz einfach in sich
zusammenfallen, wenn man zu viel ändert.
Unverändert seit Ende der 1970er-Jahre ist
auch das Botschaftsgebäude Tschechiens
in Berlin-Mitte – ein Gesamtkunstwerk.
Die Architekten entwarfen selbst
Lampen, Tische und Sessel.
Es beheimatet auch
das tschechische Kulturinstitut.
In dessen Ausstellungen
spielt das Gebäude oft eine Rolle.
Denn das Interesse
an dem Architekturstil wächst –
auch wenn er nicht von allen geliebt wird.
Also ich würd’ sagen, dieser Clash,
der besteht immer noch,
dass es entweder geliebt
oder so ’n bisschen gehasst wird.
Und natürlich ist Brutalismus
jetzt viel mehr in.
Und ich versuche eben,
Architekturbegeisterte in das Haus zu holen
und zu erzählen, was das für ein Haus ist.
Gerade veröffentlichte ein britischer Verlag
sogar eine Brutalismus-Stadtplan-Reihe.
Felix Torkar fotografierte
und kuratierte die Berliner Ausgabe.
Zu finden sind hier Gebäude
wie dieses Hygieneinstitut.
Vor Kurzem drohte der Abriss,
nun ist es denkmalgeschützt.
Weil sie so markant sind,
erleben die Brutalismus-Bauten
in sozialen Netzwerken ein Revival.
Ausgelöst auch durch Kampagnen,
die Bauwerke wie das ehemalige
Berliner Tierversuchslabor
vor dem Abriss schützen wollen.
In den 60er-Jahren,
wo diese Bauwerke geplant wurden,
damals wurden extrem viele Bauwerke
aus der Gründerzeit abgerissen.
Bauwerke, die wir heute fantastisch finden
und wo wir uns die Hände
über dem Kopf zusammenschlagen,
was da alles für Baukunst verloren ging.
Die waren damals gerade erst
so um die sechzig Jahre alt.
Genauso alt wie diese Bauwerke jetzt hier
heute sind, und wir müssen uns überlegen,
ob wir nicht dieselben Fehler wiederholen.
Gleichzeitig kommen
neue Beton-Bauten hinzu,
im Stil des Neo-Brutalismus – wie der „Lobe
Block“ im Berliner Stadtteil Wedding.
Hier dominiert roher Beton
das Innen und Außen.
Das mehrfach ausgezeichnete Atelierhaus
vereint Arbeiten und Wohnen.
Die Rohbauästhetik ist nicht nur angesagt,
sie ermöglicht auch geringe Baukosten
und hält so die Mieten niedrig.
In den letzten Jahren ist zu beobachten,
dass es ’ne neue Freude
an Handwerklichkeit gibt.
Diese ganzen Craft-Bewegungen,
und das geht dann auch damit einher,
dass die Architektur wieder mehr
zum Anfassen sein soll.
Brutalismus –
ein Architekturstil,
der vor mehr als 60 Jahren entstanden ist
und bis heute spaltet und fasziniert.